In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 29th on which we commemorate the pious emperor
Thildosios, the younger, born in the year 401.
Thildosios was a very small child when his father, Emperor Arkadios, died.
He was brought up by his sister, Bulkheria, until he was able to take over the government
of the empire, which he ruled like the Church of God.
The devil, infuri, at seeing the Church at peace, unleashed the Nestorian heresy.
Thildosios summoned the third ecumenical council in Ephesus in the year 431, which cast the
Anathema on Nestorius and his adherence.
Merciful and gentle, a friend of monks and men of letters.
The devout emperor reigned for 42 years, in the course of which he succeeded in averting
an invasion by the Huns, and had strong walls built to protect the capital.
He also reorganized the university and its teaching and had a great many churches and monasteries
built.
He gave his soul into God's hands in the year 450, after a fall from his horse.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.